they kind of go like all right well we
want
after this year gilmore girls we want
jared to beat about this show called
supernatural
um
and
so i went admit and i was wearing a
beanie big surprise and like a hoodie
and probably like flip-flops or
something
and back in 2005
the game was like if you can go in and
pretend you're james dean think you're
going to get the role you know it's sort
of like all right well i'm going to go
in i'm going to squint the do you know
the labored inhale jensen and i are our
master of this would you like to see it
sure
okay
[Laughter]
it just just gave that your whole face
changed
the whole face changed there it is there
it is
if you watch any tv show that existed in
the early 2000s you'll see a lot of
labeled enhancements
so
that was kind of the move you know
because it was like well i'm auditioning
i haven't even given the script
uh i'm reading some lines like i should
be doing something i'm going to do this
and act brooding and all that um
and so and that didn't work
that didn't work
it didn't work no no i think i think uh
david nutter
liked me who directed the pilot and the
first episode wendigo he's producer uh
mcgee
peter johnson
uh but i think kripke was like well
he just seems like he's using tricks and
i was using tricks so he was right
uh he was correct uh but then so spielo
calls he's like hey
they
i don't think they like
got really a good sense of you
um so why don't you go back in and uh
be more smart
[Laughter]
so i was like all right so i went and
like talked literature and stuff i was
like all right like shakespeare
uh theater suits guys uh like what do
you want to talk about and they're like
okay this guy doesn't know how so you
literally had a conversation and just to
show them that you're not some schmuck
well i went in and dude like i i
i have anxiety anyways i know yeah um
and so going into auditions when it's
gonna possibly change your life
you just get so nervous that you can
barely string together a sentence